welcome to the class of legends thank
you thank you it's not about me I
thought this was the legend in your own
mind class
well who's tricking me now I talked to
several members of the clubs today our
intelligent members and I told who the
legends class was and they were
deferring their brow and a vain attempt
to understand the situation and his name
is Lee NIT Stein or if you're Russian
you should slow down no really you
should you might pronounce his name
stain okay
Leonid stain Leonid Stein whatever okay
now Stein was one of the best players
never to become world champion but he
died at a very young age what age I
don't know I'm not a historian so Stein
was a very strong attacking player and
when I was a young lad of oh I don't
know 14 I had a friend international
minister Danny Edelman who doesn't play
chess anymore but his daughter does
Sadie and Danny would always say who is
better Bronstein or Stein and at this
Chess Club they would just say who and
who okay but Bronstein played for the
World Championship and was very close to
winning if not for losing him 23 right
Ken West instead he tied the match and
was never the world champion Stein never
played football championship but he won
a lot of games in all kinds of
championships for Soviet Union the
Ukraine etc now if you own a copy of my
60 memorable games by which world
champion Bobby Fischer one of his games
is against Stein it was in a real Lopez
where Fischer played on the kingside and
Stein played on the queenside there's a
really cool diagram in the book where
black has Knights on b4 and c4 and pawns
on b5 and c5 it looks really cool until
he designed that it looked less cool
okay so the first two games he's playing
Rufus and doofus so he gives them the
Smackdown but they were actually pretty
strong in the 40s okay
we got to the fifties Rufus and doofus
slow down a little bit all right not
right Arjun hi
so Stein is white okay now this game was
played in 1959 were you there watching
Ken West and my second question is we
alive then yeah did you play chess Arjun
who was there yeah no I wasn't there I I
wasn't born for 10 more years you yeah
you were there
if you're not there raise your hand okay
so they played the Queens gambit oh oh
we make an exception for Ken West the
other kind of accepted now now this is
the game Stein versus some guy I never
heard of and I can't pronounce his name
so he's probably pretty good can't
pronounce his name
it's quiet Kowski something like that
okay so he plays efore ephod naturally
the line that they plays pretty modern
so for 1959 those guys were I would say
about 15 minutes ahead of their time
pretty good okay and this is still
theory now this is actually one of the
main lines recommended by Kokomo
ballplayers okay castles and I this is
still played today 95 now you got to
remember the Preston's not why it just
seems like it okay Stein was a big
attacking player and you'll see in the
games today he likes to give the
beatdown he didn't play passive most of
the players today you're chicken and I
don't like that cuz I'm a vegetarian
right Arjun you agree you have a
question he hands us up yeah
Stein was white now this is actually a
coincidence I don't want to scare
anybody I looked at hundreds of games
because I work really hard here
in every game I found were Stein won and
played great he was white
so maybe with black not so good so
Stein's always Wyatt
now notice f7 is attacked because f7 is
attacked so black played Knight h6
defending f7 but that didn't stop Stein
you guys are like while he defended f7
so I can't take out f7 well you can't
but he did BAM okay
and after they traded thousands of
pieces then white played the brilliant
move Arjen Queen to h5 if only Kokomo
had seen it Queen h5 check and now
blacks King is running around material
is equal blacks position is probably
okay but Stein doesn't stop there he
keeps coming okay he doesn't trade
Queens like most of you would he wants
to attack the black King okay black has
a leading development but blacks King is
a little suspicious so f4 again preston
wasn't white but it looks like Preston's
white so alright so rug da f5 are all
right now in the strangest move I've
ever seen which follows all of my
theories that's why it's strange after
GF y made a move none of you would ever
predict your only chance of predicting
it is that I said you wouldn't predict
it and I said that I would play it
that's your only hope
Julian BAM is that what you would play
yeah so Queen d1
I like retreating and I like playing
Queen h5 check and he retreated them
play Queen h5 check so so Queen d1 Stein
was a very creative player not creative
like the people at the Chess Club the
creative in the good way okay so h5
stopping Queen h5 or so you thought and
now the brilliant knob kidding okay and
he plays Bishop f4 developing his Bishop
Bishop c4 tagging the rook he saw it
King he ate threatening to castle okay
actually he did castle but he did that
so I was close
Knight d2 attacking the bishop showing
the folly of Bishop c4 he takes up five
King deselect well do you cast some
Queen side okay
now you might think okay material is
equal opposite colored bishops it's
going to be a boring game not when
Stein's playing Stein always placed with
the attack Knight f3 Queen before
terrible worst move I ever saw a three
queen fi terrible Bishop g5 attacking
the rook Knight d4 and now White's upon
a head h3 my favorite move of the game
because no counter play no rook e1 check
winning for black okay now here's what
would happen if some of you had White
Queen a 7x clam rook e1 now rook F one
is probably fine rook takes e1 queen
take C one and now for the first time in
chess history
my rule must be broken and what's my
rule Arjun don't say the right move say
my rule wrong rule you with the right
answer always play Bishop f1 except here
Queen f1 mate because the bishop is
defending it okay so he didn't fall for
that he made left as my dad used to say
make lifts not wor h3 all these to the
computer you're fired Bensimon
okay h3 now there's no back rank tricks
White's upon up blacks Bishop on a6 is
terrible and the opposite color bishops
help white attack b6 making the bishop
on a6 good B for making the queen bed on
a5 Queen a for rooks see one more feel
like getting the last piece in the
attack
rook c2 Queen f4 Wow blacks King looks
really safe I don't know look nonchalant
at home don't let your dog know what's
going on okay now I should make fun of
the guys at home I got a lot of emails
and they said they beat their dogs three
out of four so I shouldn't and rook e1
Shak rook takes Queen takes Queen f3
threatening Queen a8 checkmate who would
like to raise their hand and stop Queen
a8 checkmate and as Sam Jackson would
say I dare you I double dare you
then he would say some more stuff you
know how to stop Queen it now if you if
you if you say an answer it might not be
right Arjen this should be seven is
risky because of rook e8 Shak very risky
right right so since the move to stops
Queen eight mate allows another mate
black for some reason resigned amazing
now let's give a beautiful finish for
the spectators which I just saw King b8
check then rook takes Bishop and mate
that's for the spectators okay so if I
was black I would lose brilliantly for
the spectators by black resigned
terrible
now the next guy is actually a good
player I've heard of Furman okay
not mark fuhrman Semyon Furman okay your
your favorite exponent of the black
pieces and firm was also a good player I
could do a lecture about him but even I
barely heard of him that's when you know
okay hopefully your velinski is not
watching this all right so II for now
back in the day Ken West will tell you
nobody played everything they all play
what they wanted to play Fisher style
efore that's it okay or in other cases
d4 and that's it Stein would checkmate
you a d4 and e4 and super grandmasters
have a code which I shouldn't tell you
then I have to like use my men and black
thing but I got it right I got to here
somewhere okay when you play e4 that's
called playing with your right hand and
F fours with your left okay
so he now plays with the right hand
efore and Sicilian if I was playing
somebody who likes to checkmate
everybody I wouldn't play the Sicilian
except that's the last game that I lost
okay so I guess I do play the Sicily and
get recommended okay so they please' the
Sicilian am Bishop e3 is not a
theoretical move and neither is Bishop
to d3 okay now again you might think
you're watching Preston play because no
theory and very sharp the difference is
the accuracy slight difference okay and
white play is totally crazy this game
and the computer loves it
okay and my favorite move is coming up a
three here 92 f5 alright now this move
looks like the worst move ever but the
computer says is the best so yeah so
Stein was very good at calculating
tactics and giving his opponent the
beatdown this position is very
complicated because white can't cancel
due to its illegality and White's Bishop
is attacked black has a nice light on d5
pawn structures a little dissimilar
white played the most aggressive move
any one Queen h5 check after g6 the
queen is attacked and the bishop on e4
is attacked but that's okay because the
rook on h8 is now attacked by the bishop
and g6 unleash that so white saved his
queen and now the rook is attacked
Knight f4 attacking the Queen and
threatening the bishop okay also this
bishops hanging so White has three
pieces hanging and the engines like
white ok the engines are tough okay and
white saved all his pieces Bishop takes
c6 check saving one of them and now
Queenie
three saving his queen and defending the
bishop on d4 now in a total turnaround
okay
black has both rooks attacked by both
bishops now some of you in the audience
possibly Joe Gagne our way wait a minute
why not Knight takes g2 check-forging
the king and queen ken west approved
unfortunately bishops move backwards
yeah and in fact I was giving a lesson
to Matt Larson and he played rook takes
F - and his opponent played Bishop on c5
takes F - and he wrote this shows move
backwards and then he resigned okay now
White had all of his pieces attacked and
now black has all his pieces attacked
the knight on f4 and both rooks in the
corner Bishop h6 defending the knight
and threatening Knight takes G to check
and Knight d3 check so most of you would
resign here with both colors playing
each other okay even if your clones were
playing they would resign - a lot of
resigning you agree right Arjun yeah
close okay Queenie five saving the Queen
rook c8 saving the rook and he takes the
rook in the corner and they trade and
whites in an end game with an extra
exchange in one pawn now it's like
Preston's black instead of Wyatt because
down an exchange and upon an endgame all
right
and the game got really boring because
whites I had a lot of material and I
like at the end of the game because
white made it very simple at the end
okay White's up in exchange and he got
rid of all of blacks pieces which is a
good idea and in this position he played
rook check rook check and took the
knight and black is like where do my
pieces go okay and here black resigned
because if he takes the rook takes this
then White's looking pretty good
computer probably supercomputer after
three hours would announce me maybe
this is six pieces it announces bait now
in one second this position is already
known okay so that was a nice crazy game
Stein one where blacks king was running
around eventually he won an endgame that
was against Furman who was a pretty good
player not a good police officer okay
now he's playing sakarov not these
Sakharov or as julie would say who all
right you agree with that all right good
all right so he's white because he's
white every game it plays he for again
now he plays Bishop b5 check d4 and now
the strangest move you've ever seen
Bishop h6 is pretty strange Bishop a6 I
took with a queen okay transposing into
the Queen D for Sicilian somehow okay
and this game I like because it was very
chick or an desk which I'm sure you guys
all see a lot especially Ken West and
the reason is we got two knights against
two bishops okay except both black
bishops were not as good as expected
okay took with the Jeep on those those
bishops not so good okay
luckily blacks King can safely Castle
kingside
okay d4 so Kokomo is happy b5 and this
is a very nice idea well someone who's
low-rated explained b4 b5 Kokomo I want
somebody low rated argent even lower
rated does that answer my question what
was my question okay and your answer was
C five
wait why yeah how do you know he's
kidding anymore I can't tell where you
imagine that these things you wanna quit
tonight on that guy's right whoever that
guy is
okay that guy's so right he owes me
money
that's how right he is maybe I'll hit
money if he's right all right anyway
Kokomo stay there properly there's a
pawn on c6 which makes ninety five
better for black once that pawn is gone
there's better for white okay luckily
Black has the super active Bishop on e7
he said with a deadpan Express
okay so rook c8 night h4 okay does that
smell as bad as that h3 anyone which
one's imodium which is ammonia what okay
so NH 4 and white wants to play Knight
f5 and Knight d5 and this was bughouse
you get some extra nights okay
King age 7 because the G file is open
get your King off the open file Queen f3
makes sense Knight f5 is coming
takes takes Knight d5 so this is what
Arjun likes to call a Sophie's Choice if
you leave the vent on d5 that's good for
white if you let the other night go to
f5 that's good for Wyatt and that Bishop
on e7 is good for white yeah so here the
Knights crush the bishops so chigorin's
given the thumbs up okay although it's
not really helping a much okay Bishop d8
solid Knight f5 or is Vasily escape
throw Gnaeus would say knife f5 right in
fact if you read the st. Louis and PR
column that I write which I'm sure you
do
like I mentioned knife f5 I'm sure you
read with a fine-tooth comb they threw
the comb out okay well here today gone
tomorrow all right so now White's
killing it look at his Knights
Queen d7 that'll show him 93 he wants to
keep the nigh on f5 and then Queen h6
mate will give white the advantage most
of you can't move your queen like that
when you get your rating as high as mine
or if you're Doug Eckert anyone you get
that one you saw that yeah one of our
board members at the Chess Club Doug
Eckert he's so high up in the Chess Club
he can move his Queen any way he wants
legal or not okay Bishop e7 Queen h5
always play always play the ship FA
unfortunately they should takes f5
double question mark man if it was me
I'd play Bishop f8 okay then I would
have won okay now you're going to learn
your favorite German award Canwest the
answer to that is nine cause to do the
other one
Xue Shan Zhuge after Bishop f5 all of
you are wondering Queen f5 knife f5 e f5
and none of those are right the correct
answer is kab Buchanan what Queen f7 BAM
I would bet a lot of money he didn't see
that if we could go back to 1960 we
could ask him okay black played the best
to move Knight f5 yeah and now not so
good there's good and there's not good
that's not good
so the districts lead on e7 for quite a
long time I think he played there should
be seven and left it there so that
wasn't a good Bishop I hope quite
resigned here or black somebody go back
once BAM
I went to GA then the e7 that showed him
yeah okay and and black resign remember
Stein likes to check me people I don't
I like offer a draw I don't play I do
everything but checkmate people okay now
he played zurakov as you would say or as
a rock on I don't know okay I'd ever
heard of this guy so he got crushed
efore more Sicilians and we see a rouser
Sicilian no not a rousing Sicilian
arouser named after which Grandmaster
Ken West say rouser correct well he's
never been a grandmaster
rituals are very good okay he's six this
is still like the main line today a six
the super grandmaster still play like
this okay I play black in this position
all the time this ship f4 now Ken West
is confused okay and that's not stantly
saying much now Ken wise is like wait a
minute I got two ways to win for black
okay our jinseyun you got both hands up
arjan's like I got two ways to win
he's like e five wins or I could take
and then play e5 and win unfortunately
neither one of those work are you
shocked okay let's let's find out why
play e5 we take and we take shocking
everybody except Peter Gabriel because
it was 1960 he would be shocked sometime
in the 80s yeah exactly
now pawn takes Bishop is risky because
of Queen d3 no because of Queen d4 Queen
d5 Queen DS Queen g5 attacking both
Queens no Queen takes Queen checkmate
and the whole board is destroyed and a
nuclear holocaust i and so okay so ii
five doesn't work if you trade first
which is also going to destroy the game
and then play e5 ken west who remembers
the last tactic
well now explain the next one yes this
should take c5 and as we say all France
a set of them shows we took Oh Pro no
it's the same
yeah takes and and Queen d5 Queenie
they're all bad but Queen da is good
check me okay so black played the book
move I guess it was booked in 1960 but I
didn't know about that
he played Bishop to d7 okay now the idea
is quite complicated if white tries to
win the d6 pawn he will lose his
epon and I've actually had that I've had
somebody play Knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes takes takes everybody takes
everything I think I took this and okay
material is equal black is slightly
better that's the point of Bishop d7 as
we attack the e pawn okay white plays
Knight takes and then some weird happens
okay Queen III and I think nowadays
people will play Queen e1 or f3 but okay
this is 1960s I give them a break Queen
III alright and I've had black in this
position although not this position okay
and bad stuff happened to black because
black didn't play very well from now on
blacks King stayed on ei and white just
tore him up now in my professional
opinion since Stein like to checkmate
everybody and play for an attack you
probably shouldn't play the most
complicated line in chess where that
happens play something boring if you're
playing me then you should play like
that because I like boring okay but
don't do that just hang all your pieces
all right Queen c7 breaking the pin
walking into another pin this should be
to b5 now that doesn't work White's King
blacks King is terrible
'if I've as I would say rar takes takes
Queen moves again rar
Bishop h5 and even Kokomo sees the
threat he's going to take the pawn on e6
because the F pawn is pinned but his
opponent didn't like that so his
opponent played 'if I've very positional
okay but probably losing anyway because
this King is terrible F for attacking in
the center B for counter-attack knight
retreats efore stopping the center from
getting open Knight g3 and I don't like
blacks King that's an understatement
Queen a7 most of you would trade Queens
terrible Queen b3 and now I was mildly
surprised that black resigned here
mildly and then I turned my engine on
and it blew up I dig a new computer okay
+8 for Wyatt equal material now when
you're minus 8 is equal material ban are
you in trouble
first of all Queen e6 chat is the
biggest Smackdown of all time it mates
and wins all of blacks pieces for
example let's play a stupid move Queen
e6 check if Bishop e7 then check made
with advantage and if Queen e7 that's
even worse
that's worse than checkmate terrible
alright so man Queenie six checks
annoying and is the worst position for
saw okay
so White's King very safe White's pawn
structure pretty good blacks King
terrible pawns drugs are terrible
terrible always play Bishop FA be didn't
play it just stayed there
you with some crazy comment incorrect
because Queen c6 is more powerful yeah
you'd rather check wait to play Queens
e6 if you play Bishop c6 you Bishop f7
they'll say that's not May and the hard
you
oh okay then then you should do it
alright so we have an improvement
alright so black resigned alright now
we're going to get to the real players
well not this guy why am i showing this
game alright this is a Rufus his brother
yeah Sicilian and what's this Sicilian
called anybody anyone how it wasn't
called the novice night work can help
you write the night or of Sicilian this
is the sharpest that's how they rolled
in 1960 again when your opponent likes
to check me and sacrifice probably the
wrong opening to play the sharpest
Sicilian ever gay or are are now they're
not going to play this way today they're
not going to give away all the squares
but now grandmasters today would play be
five-year but okay night BT 795
attacking the Queen he saw it well now
II 6 has tremendous pressure Queen b6
attacking the knight castles now most of
you would take the night and then Bishop
b5 Jack followed by rook takes Queen so
his opponent didn't do that
his opponent did some crazy thing
routing the computer right that was
funny okay so he played Knight fg4
threatening Knight F to forking
everything and white resigned and Stein
quit just forever class to stop now
played Bishop takes e7 Knight F to
remember when you're playing a great
attacking player leave your King in the
center and let them take the pieces in
front of it because then they'll hook
them up a little bit alright Knight f2
attacking the Queen Queen e3 tagging the
knight and defending the knight on d4
takes takes knight c6 if you play King
takes that doesn't look too safe now
I think f6 check wins and I think
F takes G 6 wins I like them both the
idea is I want to play Knight f5 check
and then Queen takes Queen also your
kings really safe on e7 right so he
played knight c6 which is crazy this
should take g6 Knight takes d4
threatening threatening threatening
knight b3 check winning the Queen and
Queen takes bishops okay
Queen g3 stopping everything now black
illegally castled although he didn't
always stop castling with Bishop FA a
rook g8 now I've been married twice and
one of my wives that can't remember
which one I remember which one she would
play the nighter of Sicilian and
occasionally she would play rugby aid
and when she played a trick GA it worked
out well for her opponent okay
don't play rook g8 when you play this
Sicilian don't do that because then your
king is on e8 and your works on g8
terrible so it's better to lose all your
pieces then play rook g8 as you'll see
here Bishop c4 blacks King is not good
Bishop e5 attacking the knight f6 always
play f6 Knight a for attacking the Queen
Bishop takes takes Queen d3 threatening
Queen takes Bishop checkmate
now the funniest move you have ever seen
yeah indeed now some of you don't think
it's legal but he did it even the
computer lets me do it now I have a
funny story because I like stories twice
students have told me this both students
were a players both students were
playing a players these are different
stories they castled with their work
through check and their opponents that
it was illegal and the director was
the directors point low-rated the new
players so there's two a players who
don't know the castling rules and they
played my students who are a players who
do know the castling rules and my
students one somehow you queen c3 check
are you trying to play Knight b6 mate
with his mission Zuger yeah yeah but
trying is the first step to failure
Queen c3 is better than what Stein
played signed by the most obvious move
yeah but that's harsh maybe your moves
not better it was funnier yeah yeah but
I just want to point out that works good
on g8 alright so that was the most
brutal of all wins because men blacks
super resign now and no matter what
Martin Martin's not going to say nothing
Martin usually says why did black resign
not here Martin's like I recommend
resigned right yeah cuz may you know
terrible yeah
also Knight b6 is good right yeah
Queen c5 is good yeah okay now we get to
the good players Stein Bronstein yeah
that's this game will determine who's
better or not the other times they
played right okay so e4 d 6 now
Bronstein likes it crazy it up and Stein
like too crazy it up so no drawers okay
so they played a modern peered something
time to opposite side Castle okay as
crazy as possible yeah it is crazy now
there's one thing I like about this game
white plays rook each three and then
plays rook back to h1 Rick G 1 and G 4
he's not he's not deterred okay and he
does you thought I was kidding but I
wasn't he told you yeah okay black
doesn't want to cancel because he's
afraid it'll get checkmated and so both
sides are going to attack the king
and he finally castles after not finding
anything better
Queenie three a four F four solid notice
if white plays f4 here Knight takes e4
is annoying so he defended his pawn then
played up for it
f5 both sides are getting checkmated
that's what you expect from Stein and
Bronstein takes all right we got four
ways to take on b3 probably not Queen
takes Oh No maybe took with the C pawn
keeping everything blocked on the Queen
side d5 opening everything up takes
takes d6 Bishop e7 and now you may have
heard in the past two bishops are good
even though Stein's two knights cross
the two bishops not these two bishops
now those are bishops now he played
Bishop e7 half of you are thinking
bishop f8 good students the other half
we're thinking our B's and the other
half are thinking wrote g6 which is what
I was thinking and the other half are
thinking band there's a lot of hands
around here okay rook takes g6 is pretty
good
Bishop takes everything is pretty good
King h7 preventing rook takes g6 I'm
pinning the F pawn Knight d4 tagging the
Queen Knight f3 to play Knight e5 or
Knight g5 they both win and blacks King
comes under too much fire BAM
Bishop e6 it's tough but fair
also White has an extra piece which is
also good and black getting checkmated
and whites queening is deep on and
whites up a piece black resign so that
was the best Bronstein could do terrible
now he's okay
okay so that was one of the best players
you ever beat until he beat your
favorite world champion was that a good
noise was that you were there was
something else I thought that was your
camera going crazy okay he beat my pet
Roshan
I mean Tigran Petrosian not to be
confused with Tigran Petrosian who plays
now yeah now to ground Petrosian died in
the 80s and when he played in the
Chicago open two or three years ago
somebody else think Tigran Petrosian one
of the directors was really impressed
that the former world champion was
playing he should have been even more
impressed since he had died over 20
years earlier
okay so Stein beat Petrosian in 1961 and
this was in the Soviet championship now
I don't know about you guys but I think
Petrosian was pretty good 1961 that's my
opinion because he was okay so Stein's
white Petrosian plays the French where's
Marla now know Marlo okay and we have
your favorite variation anybody the
winnow our Grandmaster knows okay and
then this happened okay see fought is
the main line yeah this is still the
main line okay and he played Knight f5
yeah they don't play Knight f5 anymore
they play castles but they used to play
Knight f5 that Petrosian got crushed by
Stein's are they stop this ship d3
threatening to take the knight and then
take on g7 h5 what's the threat Arjun I
said art you have to raise your hand
right and then who's better slightly
okay then you move back queen f4 Knight
c6 dubious annotations by some guy 92 ex
clan it's like a the most obvious normal
97 Knight g3 kicking out the knight
Knight g6 question mark so black played
96 97 96 showing how the knight moves
Queen d2 Bishop d7 which also the
interior doesn't like rook b1 now if
you've been to my lecture where I showed
Karpov dismantling of calm skin 1992 the
lecture wasn't a 92 it was about a year
or two ago in that game white was
winning on the Kings side and then he
started winning on the Queen side so the
rook on a1 not the best square for the
rook her could be one much better rook
b8 castles c4 not very explosive here
this should be two attacking the pawn
Knight takes g3 and now we're going to
vote it should be a landslide should be
so let's think about it and then I'll
ask your question which I'm sure you
already know the question and you can
vote at home too all you have to do is
send me money and your votes will count
double all right who votes for H takes
g3 margins like just me and who votes
for F takes G three Wow two to one
the abstentions have it okay now you
didn't take either way this was the best
solutions look at the game no I'm
kidding F takes G three because we want
the F file open for our rook and we
don't want the H file open for his rook
so f6 g3 is the best age for
Bishop to g4 and this is something
that's all of my advanced students
you're not my advanced students so I
can't tell you all right I'll tell you
we have a Grand Master in the house when
you make a move whatever you just moved
isn't where it was think about that a
little bit yeah okay my beginning
students to be like what okay so there
was a black pot on h5 I can prove it
proved it and he moved it therefore it's
not on h5 whenever your opponent makes a
move you should think about what that
where that piece was and what it was
doing well it was defending the g4
square and now it's not so Bishop g4 now
we attack takes takes what happened
all right Queen e7 terrible a4 double X
Clem these moves are played often in the
window are French because white wants to
play Bishop a3 and you can't do with the
pawn to e3 of course white will have to
play rook a 1 that takes a whole move ah
but it's worth it Bishop takes a 4 rook
a 1 and Bishop a three he got the job
done
and petrosian's king is very safe on ei
not safe okay
King on eiated ruck f2 rook f1 and then
all this stuff happened went backwards
it was edited out okay and now Queen to
d8 and argent if I was annotating this
game what would I say about Queen da
what would I say yeah baby but I would
say setting up for the next Kim yeah and
double X clam right Queen to d1 my
favorite move ever
until the next move so when you play
Queen d1 he wants the Queen to go to f3
and he wants the Bishop to go to h5 now
if you thought Queens you what was the
retreat you don't know what a retreat is
because after rook h6 now we're going to
see a retreat Julian that's a retreat
that's a retreat BAM
okay he was on a good diagonal but that
one's better
I didn't says anything wrong with it
what's right with it continue
okay what so you want to make 30 moves
in a row and take your own bishop okay
good plan good plan
yay all right then ship see one
threatening Bishop h6 simple rook aged
seven and now white made two moves at
the same time that's why he was so good
move one was the beat down and move true
was the Smackdown you BAM yeah and
backwards Bishop e6 I hate when that
happens
now the guy who imitated this game a
suspicious character he explained what
happens on pawn takes Bishop he also
explained what heavens on 9 h8 that was
very funny man a black plays that 8 she
don't know what I'll do
alright so black resigned but after
Bishop takes 6 F take c6 Queen g4 now
we're threatening Queen takes Knight
check winning the rook and Queen takes a
6 check winning everything who would
like to suggest a move for black hanging
the bishop
right I take it that's called like
saving it off one yeah yeah yeah a good
plan
that's the computers plan Thank You
tweenage for and yes Martin
Rick we're here I go check and then I
take your rook yeah that's not good yeah
yeah that's what he did
97x clam okay now after Queenie six rook
f8 I don't know which ones more I'm so
old
well Queenie sticks Rick hates shade I
can't refute I can't I'm old okay this I
know wins a queen this I can see yeah I
know yeah okay so after so after Bishop
e6 he resigned now you guys are like
yeah but Petrosian didn't lose a lot of
games and just lose a lot of games we
got crushed checkmated King in the
center
rooks doubled of the seventh rank okay
that's probably the worst crush that
anybody's ever done against Petrosian
unfortunately Stein and or stain he died
young so I think in Stein's honor we
should all have a beer
you